all right my name is Alina grips Co and
I'm one of the co-organizers of the Yale
tech conference today and I'm also the
program director at the Yale
entrepreneurial Institute up next we're
going to be discussing the next 10 years
of computer science at Yale and here to
talk about that is Joan Feigenbaum
she's the department head as well as the
grace Murray hopper professor of
computer science she received her BA in
mathematics from Harvard and her PhD in
computer science from Stanford and
before coming to Yale she was with AT&T
where she created a research group in
algorithms and distributed data at Yale
she has worked on some high-profile and
interesting projects with DARPA as well
as the National Science Foundation so
here is Joan Feigenbaum ok so over the
next 10 years
Yale has two choices that's the
university not the fiesta bachmann yale
can do what it takes to become a world
leader in computer science and continue
to be a world leading university or yale
can fail to become a world leader in
computer science and ceased to be a
world leading university and that's an
exclusive or ok now probably those of
you who have thought about this question
before saying what does that have to do
with the next 10 years that's been true
for the last 10 years so yes it's been
true for the last 10 years and during
the past year which was my first year as
chair there's actually been some changes
that some of you might have read about
now this is a beautiful graphic that was
created by one of our undergraduates
named Marcus rusi and unfortunately this
beautiful graphic can't be read so let
me read it by you so that's something I
should have thought about but let me
read it to you computer science is not a
bubble every industry and academic
discipline on earth
continues to benefit from innovations in
CS creating a more connected balanced
and informed world
I like that created connected balanced
and informed okay our universities
administration must expand the radically
underfunded and understaffed computer
science department if it wishes for Yale
to retain its stature as a modern
University I didn't tell them to say
okay this is an undergraduate he came up
with more or less the same stark choice
that I see for the next 10 years
okay now undergraduates can't wait 10
years so they started their own petition
and in general there has been a lot of
tumult over the past academic year
before the undergrad other all this
bottom-up bottom-up agitation that
actually resulted in some change so
before the undergraduates started their
petition the graduate students wrote an
open letter to the administration
published in the YTN about the fact that
Yale the size of Yale's computer science
department is a joke
if Yale wants to be a world leading
university there have been public
complaints from students and alums and
parents about soaring enrollments and no
growth in the faculty the afford that I
showed you was put up on the walls all
over the campus because there was an
online petition started by another
undergraduate called Alex Rankin and lo
and behold all of this agitation
actually produced action on the part of
the administration there were more than
a thousand signatures by students and
alumni I hope I assume that some of you
actually signed this petition and I
thank you there were 20 million dollars
into anonymous donations to the School
of Engineering which we are now part of
and the administration announced with
great fanfare and with much gratitude
from
CS faculty and the students that it
plans to expand the CS faculty from 20
ladder faculty to 26 latter faculty so a
non-trivial expansion and this is really
very big news because it's been talked
about at Yale and elsewhere that our
faculty has not been growing while
computer science has been growing by
leaps and bounds in terms of popularity
with students and importance in the
world so it's very notable that this
change happened okay reality check
among the world the current world
leading universities we have the
smallest computer science department the
one with the second smallest computer
science department is Harvard so Harvard
has recently announced plans to grow to
36 and Yale has not yet made a public
commitment to growing beyond 26 I'm told
by various people with absolutely no
details that there is talk of a second
phase of growth and that there is some
action on that front in the highest
reaches of the administration but I
don't have any concrete information
about that so that's where we are a
first step has been announced if it's
the last step we're not going to make it
so it has to be a first step towards a
big and great computer science
department befitting one of the world's
greatest universities back to this
exclusive or and stark choice so the
right choice obviously is that Yale must
do whatever it takes to become a world
leader in computer science so that it
can continue to be a world leading
university and you alumni in tech are
key players we need your support we need
your ideas and we need your money not
necessarily in that order
so I'll be here all day I would love to
hear
your ideas and I just love to see some
continued bottom-up pressure and
activity from the Yale community of whom
the Yale Tech alumni are an extremely
important faction Thanks
are there questions Jonathan
yes well that's where Yale is at this
moment Yale has six very big majors one
of them is life sciences and it's
basically pre-meds it's not really an
indication in my as far as I know of
really deep undergraduate in interest in
life sciences but the although you know
it might be but it's it's it's something
that exists at every university there's
a very big biology contingent among
undergraduates because there's a big
pre-med contingent the other big majors
are economics political science
psychology English and history now I
should tell you where we're at here is
currently and this was not historically
true English is the smallest of the big
majors computer science is the biggest
of the small majors now there's a gap at
the moment but we've sort of entered the
chasm and if things continue on this
trajectory we will cross English before
too long and at that point I don't think
there's anyone who could say with a
straight face that you know computer
science just isn't or shouldn't be part
of Yale's mainstream culture yes could
you identify yourself oh the joint cs50
okay so um we have had a very Yale has
had a long stream of complaints from
undergraduates about our curriculum our
curriculums being I don't know how to
put it not
folk real world focused enough okay so
we're changing that we're going to have
several courses next year that are sort
of real-world versions of our
introductory programming course although
we're going to continue our academically
focused introductory programming course
as well and also a real world focused
version of our introduction to computer
science class we're gonna have something
called introduction to information
systems which is a real-world focus so
when I became chair Peter Salome told me
you know I want you to start a cs50 ok I
want you to start a real world
intro programming class in the cs50
style so I didn't you know I hadn't
really paid much attention frankly to
this controversy before I became chair
because I wasn't someone who would teach
that class and I wasn't the director of
undergraduate studies and I just sort of
didn't have a role to play so I set out
to try to find someone who might teach
such a class and one of the people I
talked to was David Malin at Harvard and
we had a conversation and then the next
day he sent me an email message saying
ah here's an idea
why don't we have a joint cs50 and we'll
have students at both campuses you know
but you know basically taking the same
class in a distributed fashion with
occasional face-to-face interact
and with online interaction and a few
other ideas and the end of his email
message was culminating at the end of
the semester with a joint hackathon that
we can bill as the harvard-yale game of
CS and I thought oh well that's an
interesting idea and to make a long
story short I showed that I that email
to Tamar Gendler who's the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences Dean to peter Salome
and to Jonathan Holloway who's the Yale
College Dean and they all loved it they
said yes let's do that that would be
great fun so we're doing it now as far
as exporting the course the idea is to
have an experiment in a joint and
interactive and physically distributed
introductory course and also to have an
experiment in a mixed online offline
course so we will give the students the
opportunity to watch these you know
famous you know Sanders Theater lectures
of Mahlon but the real learning at Yale
and at Harvard and frankly in every
introductory programming course for
those of you who have never taken one
doesn't take place in lectures it takes
place in sections and in office hours
and when doing homework so we're going
to have a full complement of sections
and office hours on campus and that's
the experiment the experiment is how do
you combine best-of-breed online
resources in turn in the form of
lectures with best-of-breed
face to face on campus resources namely
your fellow Yale students and a Yale
instructor so we'll see it's an
experiment if it doesn't work we'll drop
it
we'll experiment with something else but
what we've heard from the students is
they want experiments and they want more
real-world opportunities which includes
entrepreneurial opportunities and I
should say we have another new course
that's just had its inaugural
this semester on tech and
entrepreneurship it's taught by the
adapt founder than a body and by Kyle
Jensen who's sitting in the back of the
room I think my time is up so I'll be
around all day I'd love to talk to all
of you